jeez in the early 1990s the East African
country Somali was rocked by Civil War
and subsequent famine the u.s. sent
troops there not to conquer land or
steal resources but purely to save lives
and we did that we saved about a hundred
thousand Somalis that by the way was
1993 not 1992 I misremembered it seems
like just yesterday but Somali American
congresswoman Ilhan Omar is not grateful
for what the US did on behalf of the
country she was born and no she thinks
American troops were the bad guys in
that conflict a couple of years ago she
responded on Twitter to a user who's
remembering the 19 American troops
killed during the Battle of Mogadishu
she wrote this quote in his selective
memory he forgets to also mention the
thousands of Somalis killed by American
forces that day
exclamation point hashtag not today
Satan sergeant major Kyle lamb fought
that day in the Battle of Mogadishu is
the author of the book leadership in the
shadows and were happy to have him
tonight thanks very much for coming on
tonight thanks sergeant lamb when you
read Ilhan Omar's remarks about the
battle that you fought in what's your
response well normally its humorous but
at this point it's kind of disturbing
because I mean first of all she wasn't
there she'd already left the country we
were there and I've never heard numbers
quite that inflated I mean we wish we
could have done that much damage but
that's that didn't happen as far as I
know well I guess what's so striking is
and the US has done things I'd disagree
with her around the world but in this
case it seemed like the mission was
purely altruistic we were only there to
help we didn't take Somalia I mean did
you steal gold or natural resources when
you were there no we didn't do that we
were trying to take out a deed because
he was a clan leader that had the haba
Gator clan had kind of taken over the
town they were taking the food any of
the the aid that we were giving to
Somalia also weapons and they're running
drugs khat is a big drug over there and
he needed to be eliminated so that we
could get peace back in that town so
we're actually there to help some of the
the lesser tribes or the lesser clans
such as her clan which you know
obviously they were already gone but
yeah we were there to try to do the
right thing and and you know the other
thing is we didn't say hey let's pick
out Somalia as a great place to go hang
out yeah the president at a time
President Clinton said this is where
we're going this is what the mission is
and our commander said Roger that we can
do it and and we all had signed on the
line that's why we serve and you can
make a difference when you go to those
countries does it strike you as odd that
I don't want to pick on you hon Tamar
but she's a member of Congress and so
her statements get a lot of attention
here's someone who was brought to the
United States at public expense simply
because we're a kind country that
accepts a lot of refugees and rather
than being grateful for that she spent
the rest of her life attacking this
country why well as they would say down
here in Tennessee bless her heart I mean
we we want her to understand that she's
living she's living large now because of
her family being able to escape the
atrocities of Mogadishu and yeah it's
it's very disturbing we watched our
friends get drugged through the streets
by the people that she says are her
people and we got to watch that on TV
once we'd exfilled from the crash site
that I was at and we got back to our
hanger that's what we got to watch so
yeah we take it we take it personal when
you when you attack us like that once
again it's not surprising to hear that
there's been kind of a long list of
things she said that I don't you met him
or not but she continues to say them so
yeah I feel I feel bad for her yeah I do
too what about the families of the
Americans who were killed there I mean
this what do you think they think of
this I I haven't talked to you the
families but they that doesn't take her
saying something to to remind them of
what they deal with every day right
whenever they go to a baseball game and
they they hear the national anthem they
look at the flag that dad's not there
with his kids
yeah that's a story that not just from
Somalia but all the other conflicts that
I've been in and that I haven't been in
that's the story of the soldiers so
that's what we deal with on a daily
basis and and really you know we just
want people to
to to help us out and we get back which
is we need a mission we need you know
guys to get help if they have
drug-related the military if if guys are
suffering with injuries that they try to
continue to fight with so we try to get
them the help that we can that's what we
want to do and yeah it's it's the it's
the soldier story from the last 10,000
years kind of the last thing you need is
a lecture from people like her sergeant
you thank you very much for coming on
tonight I appreciate it thank you again
god bless america